at the end of our podcast we do a thing
called unhelpful advice it's an email
you can answer it however you want and
okay
it's supposed to be unhelpful but you
could be helpful okay fine go ahead I'm
helpful bus with Bobby
kalila mr. show business
hi I'm a 20 year old Icelandic male
living in Sweden I met a girl after I've
lived there for a few months and we hit
it off and now we've been in a
relationship for over a year even though
everything is going great and we can
make each other laugh and have a good
time I seem to be losing interest in the
relationship
I've been beginning to look at her flaws
like we have different stance on wanting
children where to live and not being
able to have animals because of her
allergies but when we are together we
have fun I'm having trouble wrapping my
head around this with love your inputs
I mean it's like well you can live with
you what you can you know it's like if
if I hated animals she wouldn't be with
there's no way there's no way or it's
not her fault allergic right but if you
were allergic to animals I would really
take that into consideration
that's my consideration yeah my whole
life is I feel whole now don't get me
wrong
before I met kalila I've never have
really had an animal I mean I lived with
a couple cats when in my early twenties
I don't know their names bright because
my roommates you know but if they died
it would have been like her but but
let's say you were allergic to cats and
dogs I would find maybe some way like
get a chameleon instead or something or
like [ __ ] you know something that
would you dropped a tortoise or you know
but I think the grille question which is
not addressed in that is that what's the
sex like because if it's bad yeah if
it's or if it's not good if it's not
connected if it's not what it should be
yeah then you basically are living with
a friend you know what I mean lay off
sex to me is an extremely important
component of a relationship of course
you need everything else you know
striking a chord with us right good sex
and sex gets you know monotonous and
stale and you don't want to be with that
person anymore
and you can't consummate you can't
connect that way especially for a man
because that's I think that's how men
connect not saying that women don't
connect sexually but meant and women
need to feel emotionally connected to
have sex and men need to have sex to
feel emotionally connected that's what I
think because when we go through our
droughts and by the way in my wife and I
been together for 17 years married for
12 in June and our sex has never been
better
it's [ __ ] weird I don't get it I
don't understand but it's just but you
have gone through droughts of course
everyone goes through droughts you know
and I get all nuts you know yeah you
haven't Pacey and I don't want to like I
don't want to like try cuz I don't wanna
be like rejected and then I'm presenting
you just gotta go for it but if that
doesn't if that's not firing you know
you don't you don't have much Wow I
think yeah otherwise you and I could
live together know and have a great
relationship we could know we could I
could make you feel great
oh I can make you feel great we you
could hang out you and I I'm a pretty
good [ __ ] you and I all right we're
gonna see each other at work okay mm-hmm
we'd have a random meals mm-hmm give me
with the cast no one not mm-hmm you put
birthdays holidays we'll do a text yeah
with the Santa Clause likely emoji oh
right you know and then when we write
our books 50 years from now yeah
there'll be a couple of chapter
paragraphs yeah so yeah that's good
that's it that's good you know because
that's good you know what let me say
that well all right it's reality it's
reality you know yeah you do these
things everyone's like you know everyone
becomes a family quickly and then you
know let's keep in touch and never did
that here's another thing I want to say
that to say about that is is that I just
want to say this say don't be afraid
when I was on the last succumb I was on
animal practice it was with just in
current paddled opine I like I like them
too and we did lose contact you know I
would have dinner with just you know it
just you just write so little I'm being
real mm-hmm if in case we lose contact
all right and you know just fans and
whatnot I honestly believe and I want to
say this right now it was a pleasure
working with you you know I want to
listen right you know I'm being real it
really were you [ __ ] help me out so
much dude in my I had some meltdowns
that the producers didn't really do they
all know right now yeah what's only to
you right the producers were like oh we
gotta let's move on whatever right but
with you I just want to say thank you so
much I couldn't because I couldn't have
asked for a better number one the call
sheet number two number two number two
my seeds are always with all of them
pretty much yeah so um well thank you I
want to thank it was a pleasure working
with you if you want all over I'd have a
friendship our friendships about to die
right without your [ __ ] viewership
and I know we're watching them whatever
on Netflix we don't have time just
[ __ ] watch it you pieces of [ __ ] yeah
the kind of entertainment that we give
you here on Tiger belly for free it's
free right yeah make its $0 zero dollars
okay and the guy listening from Iceland
yeah you gotta get the sex laugh up
I was he'll it was it was he this is a
where do we pull this from this is from
email Otis yeah the email cause because
we yeah yeah people like this many
people
well nine being lost five people is fine
with a lot of vines well dude just text
me when I when I text you and maybe we
can shot my [ __ ] text you
[Music]